Lynx is a mobile
3D imaging company.
We create software that
runs on mobile devices that
allows the devices to capture
3D models and measurements as
quickly and easily
as shooting video.
We were doing
research to advance
the state of the
art in 3D imaging.
And that was successful
so we increased
the speed of 3D imaging by
two orders of magnitude,
we reduced the cost by
at least a factor of 10.
And when we decided to build
a commercial enterprise,
we had a great
technology asset and we
had to get a product
out in the wild.
So we made a decision I think
a lot of startups face, which
is do we build something right
or do we built it for people?
So we built a hardware platform
just to get it out in the wild,
learn from our customers,
do customer discovery
and market development.
And people were buying
hardware for the longest time,
but over the last two years,
the rest of the industry
has developed as well.
So in the meantime,
Google, for example,
has announced a 3D imaging
platform called Project Tango,
and our software will
soon be running on that.
And there are additional other
platform competitors as well.